hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
today a special video called taxes are a
[ __ ] I said
when you're an actor by audrey more who
from this little tiny tiny blip of an
image i'm assuming is hot guys one of
our top of wor tears a patreon server
video you requested was definitely doing
put up on the youtubes we've actually
got quite a few discussions from that
top of water coming this month and some
all reactions and today comes from sir
Jason Dolan he always requests the most
popping videos of all time or videos to
help get his friends more notice that's
usually the request and we say yes
because you're Jason and we love you
Jason Dolan mandolin
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah or when you're on a YouTube
channel damn so good all biceps yes what
happens
[Music]
it's all the book of commercial just for
sex yes you can
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi Lana
ga-oh its director Spike Jonze ya know
this was directed by she's just had to
go he was credited like job is actually
Spike Jonze dressed up as Audrey more
singing this whole song or like what is
viral thing uh I got it I wonder if
Audrey got together with fear for acting
classmates I was like you why don't we
just shot a music video here in her
acting class you know gosh you guys
havin trouble with taxes you start
improvising one day yeah that's a nice
hook but you came with a whole song
that's universal everyone can listen to
it not actor wise you'll totally get all
the plumbing construction Gary's office
job everyone really everyone was gonna
grab this cathain of the making of
behind this you know just shooting in
that one room that building has black
box felt like a theater show in a way
because I was impressed because it was
like what kind Qatar's it it's a
mandolin dude that's the Star Wars show
yeah the mandolin is Jon Favreau's the
mandolin yeah yeah so playing on the
electric guitar yeah yeah the whole song
was just her singing the whole time I
thought it was gonna eventually have
like other backup singers or other music
going and I thought it was really
impressive how it was just her the whole
time
yeah actually I really was very endeared
by how DIY this turned out to be because
sometimes these kinds of parody songs or
novelty songs can be over produced and
kind of crushed under a lot of bells and
whistles and stuff and this would
charmed me a lot just by being yeah just
one instrument and the song and then you
know this one long shot that they put
together that was not overly elaborate
but very charming that's why I said
Hanzo corrected it yeah definitely it's
just like watching Birdman all over and
you know it's great especially it's all
drums yeah that's the version of the
song I want is just to have her and one
drum I mean it's true everything she's
talking about these are real-life
struggles that actors go through anyone
who's like self employed and it's tough
doing taxes for the real rejects is the
biggest [ __ ] I mean every year it's
always something new a lot of times you
get paid through PayPal here from
whatever companies your partner with or
whatever deals you struck up and you
need like 1099s or else you get charged
like a lot more it's like [ __ ]
bizarre right yeah and yeah and they
said you need 10 a knives I'm like okay
I got it we'll get one from PayPal it's
found us out this year and there you
have to meet a certain amount of money
you made that year met that amount I'm
like so can I get my 1099 like well no
you need to have 200 transactions and
total run through PayPal so I need to
have 200 random PayPal transactions so
did you go out and buy like a whole lot
from last year to do it so what are you
supposed to try to use as possible to
get it 1099 is it for the money so we're
addicted Ono why that is but from the an
outsider's perspective that sounds a
little ridiculous yes especially like
you only hit 93 I'm like I'm even
surprised I made this particular count
for is just getting the money
disseminating it insane who's you're
talking about yeah no I mean as an actor
you do have to monitor a lot of the same
things your your mileage and our Oh God
every year I always forget the mileage
I'm always I'm like every time I go to
movie fights I should be writing down
how far I'm going and I keep forgetting
to do that download the my like you app
with the special thing we do not have a
sponsorship from them and no man we
should though we should get one we
should get one five six seven eight
this girl's very talented I'm assuming
she's one of Jason Dolan's friends
that's exactly what I feel hundred
thousand percent five I'm getting I
don't wanna make it special
yeah into it in Jason's in Melania that
makes sense
she's very talented and I was right she
is pretty yeah she's pretty she's gonna
screen these presents like t-bones you
know
yeah it's ride from all the enunciate in
front of the scene she does tip of the
tongue teeth in the lips well she could
sing to a little bit of a true threat
action saying man what I like - is it
did feel like a local theater play
simultaneously like Spike Jonze is
really the one I thought of right -
joint yeah it's no more or less than it
needs to be but it is creative and there
is subtle use of lighting and this yeah
one long take that they're you know or
they do there's a it's perfectly rough
around the edges like this was kind of
refreshing again just because yes so
many of these are hyper produced and
trying to be a lot slicker than they are
thing is the audio is great you know
yeah yeah great audio for that I was
kind of taken aback when she put away
the the Mandarin yeah she's away so I
walking to the camera I was like oh I
thought this was a live recording I
didn't realize that there's an actual
audio recorder will done in that sense I
thought it was alive like someone had a
boom just doing it you never saw that
coming
no that's what the Malaysians anyway
Jason Dolan I hope in the future you and
I can go bowling ooh let's whip out that
joint star rolling do it hit up the golf
course get a hole-in-one good one in my
heart when you send us this art made by
who I assume is your friends yeah his
name is Audrey more she is not a [ __ ]
but she opened the door for you to
request a reaction for more don't stop
there let's get some more reactions
everywhere don't get out of our hair
don't look to me for approval
I always need your approval I have no
autonomy of my own at on
autonomy economy show you out Jason
classes for pottery Jason when you get
your script off the ground when you get
that casting in there you know who you
should cast for your female lead me
mm-hmm
I mean Audrey more I think would be a
great choice to cast as the female lead
of me by Jason Dolan maybe would be the
better lead female I would be a good
lead female I think I couldn't we've
spent way too much time trying to give
you a shout out you know we love you
okay
thank you Jason for everything you've
done for us guys you can subscribe to
the reject nation go check out Audrey
morg
and check out her YouTube channel while
you're at it to the whole organization
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell subscribe to
China and we'll catch you on the
flippety-flip